نذهب الى اسطنبول هذه المره الى عامر لافي
وما اشاره المعتز قبل قليل بانه يرتقب او
ينتظر كلمه للمرشح رجل طيب اردوغان
نعم عبد القادر هنا في مقر حزب العداله
والتنميه كان من المفترض يعني او ما كان
قيل خلال الحمله الانتخابيه للرجب طيب
اردوغان
والمهرجانات الانتخابيه في الايام الماضيه
بانه سيكون له خطاب هنا من اسطنبول ثم
خطاب انقره لكن على ما يبدو الاخبار التي
وصلتنا حتى الان بانه توجه الى انقره
وربما فقط سيكون هناك كلمه للرئيس اردوغان
هناك هنا في مقر حزب العداله والتنميه
هناك استعدادات وقد اعدت بالفعل منصه
لخطاب لكن كما ذكرت واضح انه ستكون الكلمه
فقط من انقره هنا في المقر الرئيسي لحزب
العداله والتنميه في اسطنبول حاله الترقب
كما تشاهدون شاشه كبيره جدا تعرض نتائج
الانتخابات على القناه الرسميه تي ار تي
وكل الموجودين هنا يتابعون يترقبون ربما
يمكننا القول بان الان قلوبهم قلوب مؤيدين
حزب العداله والتنميه وكوادر حزب العداله
والتنميه
بفرز اصوات الخارج الامل الوحيد لكي لا
تذهب تركيا الى جوله انتخابات ثانيه هي
اصوات الخارج كما طبعا وصلنا حتى الان انه
فقط حوالي 26% من اصوات الخارج قد تم
فرزها وبالتالي اذا ما زال الامل موجود
بالنسبه لديهم كما يقولون وان كان ضئيلا
على ايه حال لان هو بحاجه طبعا الى ان
يتجاوز 50% زائد واحد اسطنبول التي كان
يعول عليها
الاصوات بالنسبه لاصوات المغتربين
نعم عبد القادر لم اسمع سالتك ان تعيد فقط
معلومه نسبه فرز الاصوات بالنسبه لاصوات
المغتربين
نعم امام ما وصلنا حتى الان ان 26% من
اصوات الخارج قد تم فرزها وبالتالي هناك
كميه كبيره من هذه الاصوات التي تتجاوز
تقريبا مليون و800 صوت كما تعلموا كما
كانت كان مجلس الانتخابات الاعلى قد صرح
بذلك قبل عده ايام اذا نسبه كبيره لكن
والفرز مستمر كما ذكرت المعلومه التي طلبت
26% من اصوات الخارج قد تم فرزها حتى الان
اذا قرابه 70% من هذه الاصوات لم تفرز بعد
وربما تغير هذه النتيجه على اعتبار ان
تاريخيا اصوات الخارج كان الجزء الاكبر
منها يذهب للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في
الانتخابات الاخيره 60% من هذه الاصوات
ذهبت لرجب طيب اردوغان الان الحديث عن
حوالي 50 الى 55% من هذه الاصوات ذهبت الى
حزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان لكن طبعا ننتظر كما ينتظر هؤلاء
ويترقبوا نتيجه هذا الفرز نعود ربما
الحديث عبد القادر عن اسطنبول هذه المدينه
التي اوصلت اردوغان الى الحكم سواء رئاسه
الوزراء او رئاسه الجمهوريه هذه المره لم
تعطي اصواتها بالكامل كما كانت تفعل دائما
عندما اعطته في 2018 واوصلته الى الرئاسه
اعطته 50% من اصوات هذه المدينه الان اعطت
لي كمالك 48
رجب طيب اردوغان قد 47% اذا نقطه واحده
فرق بين الزعيمين او بين المرشحين
والافضليه هنا لكم الحديث عن ان اصوات
الشبابيه التي رجحت وحتى الان طبعا ما
زالت هي التخمينات وتحليلات لكن اصوات
الشباب الذين ارادوا التغيير وقالوا بان
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه السيئه لم يتمكن حزب
العداله والتنميه من تجاوزها وبالتالي هم
يريدون التغيير كثير من اصوات الشباب ذهبت
هنا في اسطنبول تحديدا كما يقول المراقبون
والمحللون الى كمال كلش دارون ولكن طبعا
نحن يعني نعم كم حصل على اصوات اعلى لكن
متقاربه الفكره هنا انها اسطنبول التي
كانت دائما تعطي النسبه الاكبر للرجال طيب
اردوغان وربما كان هذا عامل مهم في عدم
قدرته الان او حتى الان دعنا نقول نريد ان
نستبق الامور في عدم تمكنه من الفوز
بالرئاسه في وقت مبكر والان ننتظر كما
ذكرت وقلت لك اصوات الخارج لكي تتمكن
ولنعلم النسبه الحقيقيه والنهائيه ربما
لما ستؤول الي هذه الانتخابات هل ستنتهي
هذه الليله ام نحن بعد اسبوعين في انتظار
جوله ثانيه بين المرشحين الاول والث